- olives salt pepper and now it's a
great start to take a little bit of sort
of life on his own will they get the
herbs coriander and basil yes
now hold them upside down yeah both
bunches one hand we're not gonna fight
around by picking it was you get a knife
yeah hold it like this
yeah clean your board first look at it
yeah just wipe it down come on Chris
every time we support we clean it I
don't know that I'm a magnet right herbs
hair and just slice around slice around
okay now just shave these down Barbara
I'm talking about the herbs yes okay
Bert
right that's the last thing we need
saving live is your ninnie okay roll
roll up the herbs rice and chop now the
important part here okay is that we were
chop them but we only good okay herbs in
okay I'm beeping yeah that's right
that's cuz it's 3 million sup right hey
dude shut up right shut up put the herbs
in okay yes turn that off please
I'm sure yep push the button that's it
could write herbs in the salsa
rious look at me colander colander over
oh yeah now we're just gonna quickly yep
now drain them let me go in there for 10
seconds now just in case you're falling
over the salsa here's a quick catch-up
for the salsa remember it's olive wool
with chopped tomatoes some black olives
seasoning a handful of chopped basil and
coriander and a squeeze of lemon
salsa done